[Musik]
für inneres bei mir in erster linie nur
ums geld für die energiewende ganz
andere welt
ich kann die übrigen anteile mitmenschen
helfer auf ihrem weg und das erfüllt
mich sehr
[Musik]
renato simonelli hat sein leben als
schweizer geschäftsmann aufgegeben um
hier im kolumbianischen dschungel mit
psychedelischen substanzen zu arbeiten
warum entscheidet sich ein ehemals
millionenschwerer unternehmer für ein
leben als schamane davon handelt dieser
film
im süden kolumbiens nahe der grenze zu
ecuador besuche ich renato simonelli
dieser ort der himmel auf erden
ich werde hier jedoch phasenweise durch
die hölle gehen menschen kommen hierher
um wieder mehr in verbindung mit sich
selber zu treten simonelli unterstützt
sie bei diesem prozess wie diesen jungen
mann mit klangstäben und
bewusstseinserweiternden substanzen ganz
flach hinlegen auf die wirbelsäule auch
simonelli kam mit dieser hoffnung nach
kolumbien
er führte ein leben auf der überholspur
konsumierte ständig kokain und ecstasy
[Musik]
finanziell sehr gut laufen vom frosch
der wissenschaft
entsprechend ist also eher langweilig
sie der sache gemacht ohne drogen
konsumiert und bin ganz langsam
unbewusst das waschmittel eigentlich
media city leipzig zeit bewusst werden
dass wenn wir so weiter machen dass ich
das über kurz oder lang open stück zeit
auf anraten zweier freunde reist er nach
kolumbien zu einem schamanen und nahm
das erste mal in seinem leben als eines
der stärksten schamanischen mittel ein
hoch halluzinogen ertrank sobald die mit
der medizin im bereich open harnik wirst
du bist du aber es ist unglaublich
schnell die pcp ch bisher weiteren sinn
im leben
es ist wirklich augenblick fragen am
prinzip des eigenen reihen richten
möchte das macht das leben schön so ist
das in zukunft auch mit blick auf die
strafbank
er zog nach kolumbien heute empfängt der
menschen die mit verschiedenen
rauschartigen ritualen ihren körper und
geist reinigen wollen in dieser woche
sind nur kolumbianer zu gast simonelli
sagt er sei der einzige ausländer der in
kolumbien das schamanen zertifikat
besitzt
hier hat aber ein anderer das sagen
don cato der kolumbianer hat das
schamanische wissen von seinen ahnen
überliefert bekommen
dieses gibt er nun an den schweizer
weiter er sagt simonelli verfüge über
eine außergewöhnliche intuition
mit dem papier noch das andere anzünden
der sünde ist an die jetzt 18 jahre der
nema ausbildet ja und jetzt bin ich auf
dem weg und es ist wunderschön dass er
als assistant eda langeweile hat erst
angefangen oder und dass das kann das
radio an bord zu lernen
aber die bereitung tanja stehen
interessant an die kranken simonelli
schulzimmer ist dieser garten mit knapp
100 heilpflanzen
[Musik]
die wichtigste pflanze hier die liane
aus ihr wird alaska hergestellt die
schamanen sagen man könne damit eine
geistige wiedergeburt erleben
immer wieder liest man aber auch von
horrortrips in der schweiz ist der jura
ska eine illegale droge
in kolumbien ist sie erlaubt das muster
einer sonne in kolumbien hat der tank
eine lange geschichte
er gilt dass medizin aber kann simonelli
da nicht in dieser kultur aufgewachsen
ist überhaupt jemals ernsthaft als
schamane agieren
jeder film inside riesige kräfte im sich
um schamane zu werden muss man diese
kanalisieren ein besserer mensch werden
zb keine drogen wir nehmen die unordnung
zurücklassen
dann ist man in der lage anderen
menschen die unsere hilfe brauchen etwas
zu geben
die pflanzen hier werden für
verschiedenste rituale verwendet
[Musik]
aber es ist so
unter anderem wird den teilnehmern
rainer tabak direkt auf die schleimhäute
gepustet
auch dieser arzt aus la plata und da
zieht sich dem prozedere
[Musik]
das ist kino sieht ist die musik die sie
dort in nachhaltig den ganzen organismus
und mehr kaputt und spricht so richtig
gesund schaut das vielleicht nicht aus
simonelli konsumiert bei den ritualen
meist gleich mit
ich werde den gedanken nicht los dass
seine frühere drogensucht hier einfach
in einem neuen kleid daher kommt
[Musik]
später sagte mir von außen betrachtet
sei es vielleicht so aus wie wenn jemand
drogen nehme aber es gebe einen
entscheidenden unterschied keine
suchtgefahr
[Musik]
sein früheres luxusleben mit einer
schicken loft am zürichsee hat er
aufgegeben er verdiente 1 millionen mit
dem import von buffalo shoes und erholte
das fitnessgerät power plate in die
schweiz
seine geschäfte gingen aber alle bach
hat er ließ seine steuerschulden in der
schweiz zurück und meldete private
insolvenz an
ich glaube bin eher luxuriös unterwegs
gewesen kochen mache mir nur selber kann
der plausch selber viel wie fertig
studien belegen dass warner music mal
intensiv frisch als chemo-therapie
einfach mit dem markanten effekt ist
gesund
und billig
es war billiges funktion dass wir nicht
in voller höhe nur der beifahrer man übt
mit der schulmedizin hat er
abgeschlossen
in der familie im minimum in fahrten
sind gestolpert und bei die mit dem mit
dem risiko von medikamenten app sich um
sterben und das ist leider ist das
letzte bild oder nähe von mama und papa
haben das sicher kein pharma industrie
ikone
es macht extrem heißt sie ja also mit
mit dem investor haben sehr sehr traurig
[Musik]
inzwischen hat er selber eine familie er
ist vor zwei monaten zum ersten mal
vater geworden
mit 50 für ihn genau zum richtigen
zeitpunkt
ich bin selber haben wir noch nichts
wunder sagt sie und erzählt mit dir im
reinen sie bevorzuge friedrich walcker
und gott sei dank an die kreisklinik der
welt seine kolumbianische ehefrau sabina
hat der vor sechs jahren in einem raster
kennt kennengelernt
wir teilen die gleiche sicht aufs leben
wir sind ganz eng miteinander verzahnten
auch während der schwangerschaft und
auch während der geburt wir haben so
viele schöne momente zusammen erlebt ich
spüre einfach er ist der mann meines
lebens zentraler punkt ihre beziehung
alaska
sie konsumieren diese hoch halluzinogene
substanz mehrmals pro monat
auch in der schwangerschaft verzichtete
seine frau nicht darauf mich verwundern
diese aussagen aber für die beiden ist
alaska keine droge sondern eine medizin
und die zubereitung dieser substanz
empfinden sie als heiligen prozess neben
der liane sind auch die blätter der dmt
haltigen pflanze ciacona die
bestandteile des tranxx übersetzt alte
erinnerungen und effekt diese lian ist
wie eine medizin ein apfel mitgliedes
den menschen wie ein fluss durch strömt
rein körperlich und spirituell die liane
muss mühsam aufgeschlagen werden dass
sie beim späteren aufkochen ii hartz
abgibt und so die wirkung entfalten kann
körperliche betätigung ist simonelli
gewohnt der arosa lernte bau spengler
und war profisportler ski
nationalmannschaft die akrobatik und bin
zwei mal 22 19
dezember in den weltcup in la plagne in
frankreich jetzt meine fresse und das
war's mit der krücke
als der kanton graubünden kreis und
heinrich strack und hatte zeit und
kaffee vertraut gemacht
diese strategie hat er nach kolumbien
mitgenommen
hier haben wir frau zu einer
franchise.de aufbaut für bäckereien mit
der main-spitze produkt in columbia
verleihen das tagesschau eine woche im
ridgewood kostet die gäste 1200 fragen
darin inklusive sind mehrere alaska
zeremonien ein geschäft mit potenzial
denn der sud aus dieser wurzel erfährt
zurzeit weltweit einheit
auch diese frau schwört darauf sie
erzählt mir von der wundersamen wandlung
die sie dank alaska gemacht habe ich war
noch jung noch im gymnasium mein körper
war für mich absolut das wichtigste
haare und ich hatte silicon brüste
es war eine total andere welt
dann habe ich abgenommen um acht uhr
morgens haben zum sex habe ich mich auf
dem boden wieder gefahr
ich weinte ab diesem zeitpunkt war ich
eine völlig andere person
ich möchte verstehen was es wirklich auf
sich hat mit dieser substanz die das
leben von dieser frau und auch das von
simonelli total verändert hat ich bin
skeptisch mein leben lang habe ich die
finger von drogen gelassen
soll ich nun tatsächlich eine der
stärksten halluzinogene zu mir nehmen
wie jeden abend beginnt um 10 die
zeremonie
vermieter gm wenig flüssige saft
richters sei etwas dahin gestorben sagt
man eine halbe stunde nach der einnahme
muss man erbrechen dann beginnt der trip
[Musik]
was mich erstaunt hier konsumieren nicht
nur erwachsene auch kinder somit brand
otx los mehr zwingend kreis 1 extrem
zumal ja was getränke der entscheid ist
immer frei aber immerhin kommen
versichert sind eben keine durchfahrt
zur abschiedsfeier sie bereits im kind
spüren das kind sich vielmehr verbinden
mit der medizin und könnte sie getan
zudem wer kennt nicht diese mengen
sondern ganz linie dessen was macht das
kind viel trinken lang verschlafen hat
wunderschöne träumen nach langem
überlegen entscheide ich mich es zu
probieren
ich will nachvollziehen was es mit einem
wirklich macht
es schmeckt nach erbrochenem und ab
gelaufen der milch während des trips ist
äußerlich wenig zu sehen
ich rase mit hohem tempo durch orte die
ich noch nie sah ich säge durch
wunderschöne farbige welten und werde in
tief düstere täler geschleudert dennoch
weiß ich zu jedem zeitpunkt wer ich bin
und fühle mich tief verbunden mit den
menschen die ich liebe es ist laut und
grell phasenweise befinde ich mich in
drei welten parallel oder schwebe vier
meter über meer
ich habe angst dass ich da nie wieder
rauskomme es sind die faszinierendsten
aber zugleich die schrecklichsten vier
stunden meines lebens ich bin froh dass
simonelli von meiner seite reicht
am nächsten morgen fühle ich mich
gereinigt obwohl ich nicht geschlafen
habe bin ich topfit keine spur von einem
kater hat dieser trank wahren leben
verändert ich weiß es nicht aber ich bin
ganz bei mir und fühle mich sehr sehr
glücklich vielleicht weil ich überlebt
habe
auch renate simonelli ist schon wieder
auf den beinen er schläft hier kaum
schon immer war sein motto mit vollgas
durchs leben
[Musik]
heute ist ein besonderer tag vor allem
auch für seine zwei monate alte tochter
[Musik]
wenn die werte zu quasi und welt von der
mediziner street was es geht im leben
ist echtes interesse dazu verpflichten
wir uns heute
das sind die gebote die ich wenn gott
empfangen habe geplant war eigentlich
das lila einen tropfen alaska auf die
zunge bekommt aber als die mutter sabine
das letzte mal alaska lahm sei ihre
tochter lila erschienen sie habe ihr
gesagt es sei noch zu früh
das respektieren sie meine lektion ist
alles ist ein prozess wie ein stetiges
polieren eines themen und renato
simonelli einst karma von arosa nach
zürich um millionen zu verdienen dann
nach kolumbien um sich neu zu erfinden
auf dem weg zu sich selbst ist er noch
immer
[Musik]